what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch
Brooklyn Nine-Nine season five episode
four today Mo F words can't so how does
YouTube count that as swearing hey leave
a like that would be awesome if you
could do that also uh full length
Reaction watch as long as you sync it
with your own copy of Brooklyn 99
available for a super sexy rejects over
at our patreon page and we cover so many
things exclusively over there as well
with reaction High to watch Longs
included let's just get right into it
people let's go
[Music]
Halloween
it's Heist time
I'm already dressed well I'm also
dressed and I made breakfast
where are my eggs in my belly
it's Heist time I love Halloween
okay here too Jake disturbing I can't
believe they got rid of pimento never
forget the show never he could still
come back
we'll hold now hope some of you have
asked me what got me through prison was
it my family don't be stupid was it
knowing that my friends would eventually
get me out of course not I never
believed in any of you no the only thing
a championship cumberbund or belt as
normal people call it no it is well
whatever it is this year the competition
is not limited to winners of the past
Heights it's open to everyone every man
for himself it's like Bachelor in
Paradise it's really cool that you guys
open it up to anyone people joking about
that not joking insult me all you want
for I have only this to say Victory
shall be mine oh I feel like there's
gonna be more because you're both losers
there it is none of you stand a chance
against me no courage no patience no
brains and of course
old man I'm younger than you no comeback
for the bald thing I see yeah I'm not
doing the heist I'm out what nope nope
you're good Jeffords but not good enough
in fact you're an idiot I should have
fired you long ago chill out get your
undies out of your buns I hope you win
Terry will not be locked up or hidden
away it will be suspended from the
ceiling in plain sight for all to see
how poetic it will hang just Out Of
Reach like tenderless fruit yes
mythology not an episode of the
Nickelodeon show guts throwback
[Music]
let the games begin everybody just grab
something random back off Hitchcock
silence
he knew it it's like a murder mystery
still in this room it's right here it's
just your tum tum I don't have the
cumberbund because it's right here or is
it right here yes
without me
[Music]
stuff that I didn't want to assemble you
get a clue for each item you put
together Lynette
Charles got this I mean no one is
actually gonna do Gina's dumb chores
right absolutely not it's completely
ridiculous
guys
Hitchcock and skeleton end up wearing
half this stuff ah whoa and right on
time here's Bill welcome I'll see you me
neither I brought him back did you have
any issues getting into the vents sir
only authorized Personnel allowed up
here oh detective Boyle didn't see it
was you you better ask you oh man
I'm friends with officer Lou not anymore
Whoever has it at midnight will be
declared the winner of the fifth annual
what's going on what's Happening
everyone just grabbed something randomly
you spent so much of the taxpayers money
you gotta get better electrical security
for your Precinct I made 90 000 this
year alone working out of the comfort of
my own home nutraboom right and the good
news is yeah you can do it too yes
clearly a pyramid scheme we're not
interested no okay your loss here's the
belt ah She's a Beauty one bummerbund
this is crazy you're never gonna get out
of here with that belt on your own I'm
not on my own I have an alliance
whoa yeah I knew you were playing last
year was a setup hell yeah it was I'm
sick of you Amy and whole winning you're
all so damn smug
this year belongs to the tramps girls
that's a bad name Bill keep an eye let's
go tramps Charles no no hey let me ask
you this would you like to Be Your Own
Boss not now Bill
how would you like to work half as much
but make double the pay it was just a
ruse so you and Charles could steal the
belt yeah but also Charles teamed up
with Rosa and Terry to form the I
gave Charles the idea last year
what are the Champs I'm just one of the
tramps ooh the tramps that's a great
name for something I just don't know
what
[Music]
I'll always be one step ahead of you you
can't surprise me you know what spices
up a relationship co-owning a
multi-tiered marketing ignore him it's
the only way we're gonna win is if we
team up good point rotten hell Crap Face
gosh you're being so mean go who needs
you you freaking Jack good job guys
servers okay Sarge lift up the super
heavy thing that no one else is strong
enough to lift
whoa
I set up an electric eye yesterday so if
anyone enters this room and alarm will
go off don't cross the beam
cross the beams
for the streams
that's something I can do without any
problem
Oh Boyle
all right fine looks like I'm gonna have
to 127 Hours this Stitch you're gonna
cut off your own arm that out ends oh
man I got busy in my rental period
expired I thought he just wiggled out
double the amount of supplements that
Boyle did eight thousand dollars what he
gave you four grand he invested it in
his future and you can too I already
agreed to it you don't have to keep
selling me sorry the script we're given
anticipates a lot more resistance
of course
something's going on with this Heist why
are you sweating I'm not sweating I've
had enough heart attacks to know what
sweating looks like not sweat
it's like the Key and Peele meme well if
I'm sweating as you played it's because
I was watching an exciting video on the
net really
it's like some jigsaws
it's highly erotic you're lying I.T
Justin stall blocker software thanks to
Moi uh yeah all right Corgi
now if you'll excuse me I have to grab
some fresh air
[Music]
decorations
this is isn't the championship cameraman
this is some common cumberbund you're
not cheddar here's some common
what happened to Cheddar I don't know oh
Jake they check in every 10 minutes and
I have to respond with a code Only We
Know I am a
did I guess it did I guess the code I
couldn't hear it Rose's head back but it
was the first thing I guess was that
right you got it yeah I thought so okay
jeez
but that's not cheddar Halt and ched are
always walking a perfect clock step
which means someone took cheddar and
that person has the belt but who who
took cheddar that's Gina it actually yes
you were going a long time friend you
feeling okay friend no it was number two
and it was very intense friend
bless you
she sneezed dog allergies Amy took shut
up shut up where is my dog aren't you
standing right next to him this
one of you took cheddar and you did it
for the sake of the heist but if
anything happens to him I will whoa whoa
Captain neuter cheddar but I will neuter
you all wow
[Music]
Bing pot
sugar cheddar
Shake oh good grip pristine code that's
my doggy you betrayed me you'll explain
yourself later return to my office
guys
Amy won't shut up about how relevant
that show is in today's political
landscape but I'm not doing anything
curiosity loved the show I love
Elizabeth Moss Terry thought the show
was too late
[Laughter]
oh my god oh they're circling
I don't know what's going on I do
handmaid's out
it's like the costumes from the second
one well it's almost midnight why don't
you try and use your key it fits oh it's
not turning use your key to open the
safe and act like a dick about it yes
obviously that's what I'm gonna do Rosa
I just have to be so spot-on all the
time
I put a GPS tracker on the Belt it's on
the move and it's going fast let's take
my bike they'll never catch us the dog
or dorks should we follow them
why are you giggling I put a GPS tracker
inside of Terry Sarge what one too many
full fat French yogurts you want it
absolutely
oh my God
enjoy couldn't see that I'm sure it'll
be fine he's lived a long life already
yeah oh
sorry I'm like a maneuver one of the
handmaids I'm assuming fake Charles took
my safe and then of Amy deposited a
look-alike
what did you give fake Charles so we'd
help you nothing in fact he gave me
something the power of Financial Freedom
big Charles broke into the safe remove
the tracker and let Terry and the whole
squad on a wild goose chase I'm always
gonna be one step ahead of you it's
midnight so I guess I'm an amazing human
slash genius except you might want to
read the inscription on that they're
built why oh no what does it say
Amy Santiago will you marry me
whoa
what surprise
for real
[Music]
what a great way to distract to get the
belt
I don't trust it if this is part of the
heist I will dump you so hard no please
hey it's like it's really happening okay
it's not part of the heist I promise
this is real what also for reals I love
your butt I love yours too gross
Amy Santiago
will you marry me wow Peralta I will
marry you
and put on the Belt this little trap
Escape so that ought to teach
just
checking Amy
great stuff great stuff so since Peralta
altered the cumberbund no one really won
the heist this year her altered did you
call any stat first I actually did Mr
Santiago I'm calling to inform you that
I plan to ask your daughter to marry me
I am not asking for your permission as
she is not your property nor would she
be mine if she chooses to say yes
it's a voicemail everyone
said I planted the idea in Jake's head
eight years ago oh hi I'm starting today
detective Santiago Dr Peralta welcome
aboard I'm hearing Wedding Bells hi
detective oil I'm actually really slowed
things down it took like four years for
me to forget that memory yeah I'm My Own
Worst Enemy look no one gave me excited
to ask Amy to marry me all on my own on
April 28th there's a typo in this
crossword puzzle
[Music]
oh congratulations I'm so happy you two
are getting married for getting married
we're
here
get over it you jack yeah you jack
wow wow wow wow
wow did not see that coming did not see
it coming
not playing game properly to a romantic
in the fantasies but who win the heist
oh sorry I've declared it's over
You've Lost Your Role well that was cute
twas
what's going on what was going on there
it wasn't my fly I wasn't sitting here
like you know it's just uh there's a
side pocket and I don't want anything to
fall out because if I've learned
anything about basketball shorts and
sweatpants it said the pockets aren't
made for pocket stuff when you sit down
Amen to that sister
yeah that's about time to get married
holy crap
person will do that to you and I like
what the moment that
made him realize that he should propose
just a cute little real moment of seeing
who she is
nothing big or logical decision
it was just ah I love her for her weird
idiotic syncreases is the worst of what
it is beautiful that was a really nice
moment eloquent you know if we haven't
brought back that whole thing with hole
with the Mobsters oh yeah out of there
it's been a few episodes they haven't
followed through with that jackasses
Jags but nah that was a fun one and
does that mean we're not gonna get in a
heist episode next Halloween that's a
good way to throw a surprise in there or
it's not about the proposal
time you least expect it to come yeah
and the next Halloween we can go back to
it you know we we they can probably use
this as some kind of excuse to make it
an even bigger crazier Heist because
somebody has to win yeah but yeah you
know five heists in I feel like it's
appropriate to switch it up I I feel
like yeah it's like the first couple
you know they did a nice job of having
just the heist and throwing us off the
track and then uh you know as they've
grown they've gotten good at subverting
and twisting things and then here yeah I
thought it was appropriate at first I
was like we're just not gonna No One's
Gonna find the but it's not about that
and I appreciate that it's not really
about that it's like it's like all you
get all the fun in the lead up
yeah so listen guys before doing this
channel I was working at a doctor's
office and then before working at a
doctor's office I was part of a network
marketing company
and John was part of it for like a month
too is a couple months yeah yeah failure
drove yeah I mean it was failure you you
had the juice to make it work and uh and
I was I didn't really make it work this
made it look like I was making it work
but that's what it's all about it's all
about man
um did it for years worked my life
uh it was an experience that had some of
the best lessons I've ever learned I
don't just mean that learning from
mistakes or actions that I've done that
were bad I mean they taught me some
great things at the same time there's a
lot of things I learned from mistakes
and terrible things that happened there
so
everything that they're joking about
here I am the target market audience
because yeah that is
especially that live life there's
usually more resistance like you guys
have no idea they call it opening uh
yeah yeah
prepare for objection use specific
terminology yeah it's not a pyramid
scheme your job is actually a pyramid
scheme is a guy makes all the money this
is fair equal so the seminar and
orientation it is a training touch you
had a handle when someone used the
pyramid scheme objection is great uh but
yeah I know that was really funny to me
I hit on a real personal note I don't
really talk about those days I think I
have a video somewhere online about it
when I was like I think I want to be
like a diamond director that was those
positions they call like gold director
still I met the silver
work hard that week so you're right here
I think I wanted to become a diamond
director
talking about goal setting and I
took all that stuff there like the good
stuff about goal setting and striving
that and brought it to here man so I did
learn a lot I did learn a lot it wasn't
all bad can't say that still friends
with a couple of those people from there
God bless their souls I I think there's
a lot that you can learn from there uh
same time yeah I always liked it to the
Batman Begins movie that's how I always
said for years been saying it that way
it's like how Batman was part of League
of Shadows if Batman Begins and
eventually he was like you know what
there's some things about the way you
guys conduct business around here that I
don't agree with someone it takes some
of the good things I learned and I'm
gonna take it back over me and go do
something else
I'm gonna lose some of this other stuff
on I want to take the ethic yeah and I'm
gonna separate that and I'm Gonna Leave
the Shady yeah predatory behind yeah so
um I totally think that there's a lot of
good things from there but no I don't
ever talk about that time in my life
because network marketing has a weird
negative slant to it for some reason why
it's just because people are average and
they'll be that way forever yep
um so yeah that was funny and you know
married now
so that hit on another personal note
and I don't care relate to anything no
he's hitchcocking skulls I am Hitchcock
Scully today or Terry with the yogurt
maybe a little bit uh you know there was
Halloween decorations I love Halloween
so I really identified with all the
light up skeletons and old timey
jack-o-lanterns they had around
um
I've been a prostitute before so I I can
relate to to not boil I was glad they
brought him back I thought that was fun
there was technically a winner
yeah true I mean somebody has the safe
no he just changed the inscript hold
said Hold Steady change the inscription
that's not a decoy belt it's just that
they changed the inscription on the Belt
yeah okay and he was saying that because
he changed it there's no winner that's
what he was arguing okay I see it but
he's he's still technically I thought
that wasn't the original belt that's
what I thought at first too but Hulk
said that line and I was like oh it
might be the original one he just
changed the description is that what he
said I could have sworn he said he
changed the inscription I'm going to
trust you for now I feel like you don't
want to trust me I I heard plenty of
comments right totally get something
wrong uh constantly well that would tie
things up nicely because then it would
be like oh yeah she kind of does win but
she wins something even greater than
that I'm gonna just check it to the very
end it won't be hard to find yeah let me
just check
um
that's hilarious okay funny
no one really won the heist this year
altered the cumberbot there you go yeah
truly okay yeah so yeah so there is it's
all wrapped up it's all there
it's good see so yeah there's
technically a winner yeah you just
altered it they're still midnight still
got the cummerbund yeah that's a weird
technicality to abide by yeah I feel
like you know it's still if it's made of
the same original materials though
altered slightly it still counts they're
like the ship a thesis uh it's an object
it's the same object though yeah yeah
yeah the Engravings changed around yeah
it's matter has been slightly
re-articulated and they couldn't trust
us as suspend our disbelief enough to
show us
the inscription on it to show how Jake
changed it yeah in time and then they
would have had to have gone to the
trouble of showing like well how did he
alter it so fast without you know lots
of equipment and calling attention to
himself yeah
but what do we know what do we know
not much all right well there's still so
much more to go through with this season
there's still so much more unpack but
that was a fun cute episode
and liked it
um I'm happy I'm satisfied I'm satisfied
I'm satisfied I got a double dose of uh
Halloween time sandbergs this week why
because he's in he's like one of the
main supporting characters in Hotel
Transylvania
he and Selena Gomez love interests
together
which in animated form is not creepy
no no no
I don't know there you go it's not
creepy in real life either I guess not
they're not that far apart age-wise
who cares
true that age is just a number man
do what you want Dane Cook makes a lot
of jokes about his wife
and that makes it not weird now of
course yeah yeah I acknowledged it yeah
as long as you lamp shaded it's good
how old is she like
17.
she's like
I think in less than half his age sure
she's like 20. yeah after she's a hot
young thing sure
I've never heard someone say hot young
thing
yeah I feel like yeah somebody somebody
much older would say hot young thing
that's us that's us we're the new Danes
cook Pete Davidson dates like
five-year-olds
yeah no true that everyone's like how's
he can't always win you know those are
five they don't know any better they
don't have any judgment the concept of
dating or relationships really no no
he's teaching them he's he's learning
the youth yeah is is the stand up good
is Dan Cook's new stand-up after snow
here is good no it's
I thought it was really bizarre I was
morbidly curious but bizarre
why
it's in his backyard of his house okay
and there's a lot of these shots like
drone shots showing like what it's
overlooking the crazy view he has look
how cool my house
a lot of look how rich I am this is not
and it doesn't really have like a
through line and it it's just a weird it
was a weird set it was like it was
strange
it's weird as I saw him at the comedy
store years ago and he had like
hilarious material and I never saw any
of that material in any of the stand-ups
he's done
whoa
that's that's just odd to me I mean I'm
sure it happens but a guy like that I
feel like
you would want to record as much of the
gold as you can with as much as people
debate your comedic Legacy
yeah that was uh
that was weird
anyway guys
um thanks for being here Brooklyn
Nine-Nine is done see you all soon
peace out reject Nation